bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 15 avril
un convoi de réfugiés dans l'ouest du
kosovo a bien été bombardé hier par
l'aviation alliée interrogations sur le
rôle et la présence des serbes
l'erreur de guerre et reconnu par l'otan
explications sur les conditions dans
lesquelles cette information a été
diffusée depuis belgrade
nous serons en direct de la capitale du
monténégro avec maryse burgot car l'otan
vient de bombarder des positions serbes
au monténégro nous évoquerons de
nouvelles tentatives de déstabilisation
du régime du monténégro et nous irons en
macédoine pour évoquer l'état sanitaire
des réfugiés élections présidentielles
tronqué en algérie malgré le retrait de
six candidats sur sept les électeurs
algériens se sont déplacés mais en
beaucoup moins grand nombre
à londres le ministre de l'intérieur
britannique autorise la suite de la
procédure d'extradition du général
pinochet mais la suite sera longue
orfeo de monteverdi l'un des premiers
opéras connu est présenté à paris au
théâtre des champs elysées et jusqu'à
samedi soir l'otan a donc reconnu avoir
bombardé des véhicules de civils à
l'ouest du kosovo
hier près de 24 heures après le largage
d'une bombe sur le convoi par un pilote
de f 16
le porte parole de l'otan a admis ce
tragique incident selon son expression
tragiques incidents qui auraient fait 20
morts selon une dépêche de l'agencé
france presse
75 selon les serbes commentaires eric
monier même lieu mêmes protagonistes
pour ce 23e jour de bombardements et
cette conférence de presse désormais
rituelle au siège de rillieux sans cet
après-midi l'ambiance est pesante
lorsque j'ai michy le porte parole de
l'alliance s'avance au public et ce
qu'il croyait être des véhicules
militaires dans un convoi
ils étaient convaincus d'être sur la
bonne cible
il a lâché sa bohème de bonne foi comme
on peut l'attendre de la part d'un bon
pilote appartenant à un pays
démocratique membre de l'otan à ce
moment là le pilote a dit qu'il attaqué
un convoi militaire
la bombe de l'otan a détruit le
kühl de tête donc nous croyons
maintenant qu'il s'agissait d'un
véhicule ici précédent le communiqué
officiel et sont beaucoup de détails
après 24 heures de ce que l'otan
appellent une enquête conclut cas de
réflexion l'alliance reconnaît la base
du gmi chi au nom de l'otan regrette
profondément les pertes en vies civiles
sans être toutefois capable donc
confirmé le nombre 75
si l'on en croit les serbes dans un
enregistrement diffusé lors de la
conférence de presse l'un des deux
pilotes de f 16 impliqués dans le raid
pilotes dont on ne connaît ni le nom ni
la nationalité donnera sa version des
faits il dit avoir vu des maisons
brûlées depuis trois véhicules verts
foncés qui lui ont semblé être les poids
lourds il s'est alors forger une
conviction j'ai pris la décision à ce
moment là que c'était les gens
responsables des villages brûlés que
j'avais vu jusque là j'ai alors engager
mon système de visée sur le véhicule de
tête est là et une bombe guidée laser et
détruire le véhicule de tête une version
des faits qui est loin de faire toute la
lumière
car hier près de diaconie de ça ce n'est
pas un mais bien deux convois civils qui
ont été touchés par un bombardement
le premier pour nous vous montrions déjà
les premières images hier près de mea au
nord de dia cowitz le second à 12 km au
sud de giacobbi de ça aurait fait au
moins 13 morts
lequel de ces deux convois l'otan
reconnaît-elle avoir touché hier qui a
touché le deuxième combat de questions
sans réponse ce soir nous avions diffusé
les images venues de belgrade montrant
le convoi bombardé et les corps des
victimes
image de mort images difficiles mais il
a fallu presque 24 heures pour recouper
des informations issues de différentes
sources nous avons voulu ce soir vous
permettre de mieux comprendre quelles
sont ses sources par quel cheminement
les images et les informations sur ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur du kosovo
sous contrôle serbe parviennent jusqu'à
nous
reportage d'olivier galzi parce qu'elle
dit c'est bon et guillaume sotra ces
images ont été tournées sous le strict
contrôle du centre d'information serbe à
pristina
assorti de cet avertissement elles ont
fait le tour du monde
partis du lieu de la tragédie en passant
par la double sens sur de prestige 1 et
de belgrade
elles sont arrivés au siège de l'agencé
qui tiennent à londres
et pitié n est l'une des rares agences
d'image encore présente au kosovo
romane notre cameraman basée à pristina
est parti avec les serbes sur les lieux
du drame et il a filmé mais nous n'avons
aucun moyen de le contacter directement
tout ce que nous savions alors c'est que
le bombardement avait eu lieu mais de
quel bombardements s'agissait-il en
envoyant ses images aux télévisions du
monde entier
l'agencé elle-même ne le savais pas pour
mieux comprendre l'histoire de cette
information nous nous sommes rendus au
siège de l'agencé france presse à paris
son journaliste basé à pristina a lui
aussi fait partie du voyage de presse
organisé par les serbes
à 16h10 si hier il sera le premier à
rendre compte de ce qu'il a vu à mai à
vers 13 heures 13 heures 30 ans à peu
près d'après ce qu'on a cru comprendre
lui ce bombardement danser dans cette
zone
une heure après à peu près d'être
correspondant appelé chine a été averti
par le centre d'information ferme de
pristina qui a immédiatement organisé un
voyage sur sur les lieux avec notre
correspondant et enfin donc d'autres
journaliste qui se trouve actuellement
après china et il est arrivé sur place
un peu avant 16h j'imagine vers 15h30
votre journaliste et sur place à peu
près vers 15h30 c'est à dire trois
heures après le bombardement qu'il va
constater
or l'otan déclare que ses frappes à
elles ont eu lieu à 15h30 au même moment
donc on parle pas de la même chose
c'est possible je sais pas toutes ces
questions illustre bien nos difficultés
comment donner un sens aux images qui
nous parviennent
ce soir encore personne ne peut dire
avec certitude si les morts que l'on
voit sur ces images sont les victimes du
raid manqué de l'otan ou celle d'un
autre bombardement
moscou accusé l'otan du bombardement sur
les réfugiés et exigé une enquête nous
le secrétaire d'état allemand aux
affaires étrangères s'est déclaré choqué
par ce bombardement et puis à belgrade
ont par contre d'actes délibérés parmi
les réfugiés albanais du kosovo qui ont
franchi la frontière et qui sont depuis
ce matin en albanie à maureen à certains
d'entre eux faisait partie du convoi
bombardé commentaires nathalie mosan à
la frontière de maureen la nuit dernière
ils sont choqués épuisé ces réfugiés
faisait partie du convoi de tracteurs
touchées par les bombardements de l'otan
il était 13 heures il roulait vers la
frontière albanaise lorsque distille
plusieurs avions les ont pris pour cible
j'étais dans le convoi détracteurs il y
a eu une explosion très proche
j'ai couru dans les champs comme une
souris j'ai pas honte de le dire parce
que je suis trop vieux pour mentir tout
le monde courait on a entendu une femme
dire oh mon dieu
l'otan nous bombarde l'otan où les
serbes qui a tiré les récits des témoins
du bombardement sont contradictoires
défense de sécurité sert nous ont
arrêtés ils ont demandé à mon père s'il
par les serbes
puis ils nous ont dit de ne pas dire que
les serres nous avait tiré dessus mais
de dire que c'est l otan ont marché à
l'arrière du convoi
quand on est arrivés près du pont j'ai
vu des morceaux de chair humaine partout
des jambes des mains qui est des gens
sans leurs mains soulagés d'être arrivés
en albanie il ne s'explique pas ce qui
s'est passé mais aucun ne parle de
véhicules serbe accompagnant leur convoi
avant l' attaque
plusieurs de ces réfugiés refuse de
croire qu'ils aient pu être bombardée
par l'otan dans concernant ces
bombardements ses frappes de l'otan sur
l'aspect plus strictement militaire sur
la technique utilisée par les avions
f-16 de 5 km en deux temps la belgique
le danemark et pays-bas la norvège et
les états unis
voici quelques explications avec laurent
boussier bon usine piste d'atterrissage
dépôt de munitions casernes ou encore
voie ferrée et raffineries de pétrole
toutes ces infrastructures de l'état ou
de l'armée yougoslave prise pour cible
par les avions de l'otan depuis trois
semaines ont un point commun elles sont
fixes repéré depuis des mois par les
services de renseignements militaires
photographie analyser leurs coordonnées
géographiques sont intégrés dans les
ordinateurs ou les calculateurs des
missiles de l'otan qui vont les frapper
avec une redoutable efficacité
c'est le résultat des armements précis
qui ont été développés dans ces
dernières années soit qu'ils soient des
armements type tomahawk you ou lancer ou
équivalent lancé par avion à guidage
très précis soit qu'ils soient des
bombes ou des munitions guidées par
laser avec une tache laser avec des
précisions qui sont de l'ordre de
quelques mètres pour ces frappes ou les
pilotes n'ont pas besoin de voir leurs
cibles les avions restent généralement
au dessus de 5000 mètres d'altitude au
maximum la survie de l'avion et bien sûr
du pilote
l'équipage donc nous effectuons nos vols
et nos opérations à en haute altitude
le problème se pose de manière
différente quand les cibles sont mobiles
convoi militaire concentration de
troupes colonne de chars en mouvement là
pour toucher à coup sûr il n'y a que peu
de solutions la première consiste à
infiltrer au sol des commandos qui vont
grâce à un faisceau laser guider une
bombe larguée à haute altitude
la deuxième solution est de faire
descendre les avions près du sol pour
identifier visuellement leurs objectifs
mais là le pilote prend des risques
c'est pourtant le rôle de ces avions
furent de chars harrier ou à dix toute
autre solution pour tirer sur des cibles
mobiles est aléatoire ou source de
méprise sur les objectifs des frappes
aériennes contre la yougoslavie vont
être intensifiées jour et nuit rappelé
aujourd'hui encore l'otan et le
déploiement des premiers hélicoptères
américains apache en albanie a commencé
pour la 22e nuit consécutive belgrade
comme des villes du centre et du sud de
la serbie ont été visés mais la
télévision serbe montre d'autres choses
de la vie quotidienne commentaires
françois cornet
effectivement place de la république cet
après midi dans la capitale yougoslave
sur la musique d'un feuilleton populaire
symbolisant la résistance de belgrade
durant la seconde guerre mondiale les
habitants sont redescendus dans la rue
pour réaffirmer leur soutien à stoneham
milosevic
ici on est loin du kosovo et de tous ces
drames comme celui d'hier qui fait
aujourd'hui bien sûr les grands titres
des journaux yougoslave
peu de réactions toutefois sur ses
places de belgrade où l'on essaie
d'oublier dans la journée
les alertes aérienne de la nuit hier
soir à la périphérie sud ouest de la
capitale
les avions de l'otan ont frappé à
rakovica une caserne de l'armée
yougoslave que la télévision serbe se
garde bien de nous montrer après ce raid
en revanche elle n'hésite pas à diffuser
largement
ces images des dégâts collatéraux comme
les qualifie le temps de ces
bombardements des avions de l'alliance
de l'image de propagande largement
exploité l'océan yougoslavie celle du
grand-père slavneft loukachenko
président de biélorussie au chevet des
blessés civils victimes des raids de
l'otan
ce soir comme hier soir les belgradois
abordant un gigantesque drapeau
yougoslave se dirige sur les fonds du
danube et de la save pour former un
bouclier humain face aux bombardements
l'otan a pris pour cible en fin de
journée la banlieue de podgorica
capitale du monténégro le port de bach
seul port important de la fédération
yougoslave sur l'adriatique a été touché
par plusieurs missiles tomahawk tirés
depuis les navires de guerre américains
en macédoine plusieurs centaines
d'albanais du kosovo sont arrivés ce
matin au poste de blatche et ainsi qu'au
niveau du village de l'eau jane dans le
nord-ouest les réfugiés arrivent par
petits groupes le long de la voie ferrée
vers le poste de contrôle de la
frontière macédonienne une nouvelle
vague qui est estimé à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes est
attendue depuis le 24 mars plus de cent
mille réfugiés sont entrés en macédoine
la police macédonienne a prévenu la
croix-rouge de ses possibilités de
nouveaux arrivés et puis la mise en
alerte de l'accueil humanitaire ne porte
pas seulement sur l'hébergement mais
aussi pour prévenir des épidémies vous
tentez de subvenir aux besoins
sanitaires les plus urgents hervé
brusini et philippe naudy était abrash
da en compagnie d'une représentante de
la croix rouge yolanda est enfin parvenu
à la retrouver cette famille en
allemagne
le père un immigré albanais avait tapé
les miens sont ici ont ils dit retrouvez
les à présent pour la responsable de la
croix rouge internationale
le devoir est accompli ils partiront
bientôt pour berlin si tout va bien ils
sont vingt-cinq mille abraj da ici
toutes les familles sont disloquées et
même à l'intérieur du camp parfois des
enfants se perdent
il ya deux jours c'était le cas d'une
petite fille alors là c'est nouveau
c'est le cas qu'on peut trouver chez
nous dans les supermarchés c'est
l'enfant qui se perd je les grandes
surfaces c'est juste demandé
près de retourner immédiatement au point
là où il avait trouvé la petite est de
passer par parleurs le nom des parents
consacrent leur sont utiles et là
effectivement en fait le frère était
dans le coin dans les environs d'ahl et
voilà sa petite soeur puis mes parents
sont effectivement cinq ou dix tentes
plus loin et on n'a plus un pull à
redonner à ses parents cela fait sept
ans qu'elle fait ce métier toujours
heureuse d'annoncer une bonne nouvelle
toujours solide devant la vulnérabilité
est ici elle est souvent extrêmes cette
fois il s'agit d'affronter le cancer une
jeune femme demande à partir pour la
suisse avec sa mère gravement malade
elle à la bad et cousins mais il ne sera
pas simple de convaincre genève et puis
une autre femme est arrivée
moi aussi j'ai un cancer et j'ai très
mal
elle voudrait aller en allemagne presque
impossible à présent ce sont deux
handicapés mentaux on ne sait comment
ils sont arrivés là
incapable de s'exprimer il faudra des
photos pour aider les familles à les
retrouver mais comment ne pas se sentir
écrasé par toute cette misère
oui répondent en fait cette question
parce que quelque part
effectivement il ya beaucoup de misère
et puis en même temps en tout cas pour
l'humanitaire j'ai l'impression qu'à
chaque fois on trouve une autre sens là
dedans aussi
et puis elle a voulu en avoir le coeur
net la première famille de réfugiés à
l'est elle vraiment pouvoir partir en
allemagne comme prévu
la nation le départ était compromis
demain yolanda s'est juré de faire une
autre tentative sommes maintenant en
liaison avec podgorica la capitale du
monténégro et maryse burgot maryse des
bombardements de l'otan ont eu lieu il y
à quelques instants je crois près de la
capitale
oui enfin c'était vers 18h45 ce soir
nous avons entendu des bombardements
assez intensif ici à podgorica les
forces de l'otan ont frappé à plusieurs
reprises elles ont frappé entre autres
un site militaire à tout dix à quinze
kilomètres d'ici elles ont aussi frappé
le port maritime de bach comme vous le
disait françois corner tout à l'heure
d'après nos informations les forces de
l'otan ont répliqué à des provocations
de la marine yougoslave qui est
effectivement très présente sur la mer
adriatique
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que ces
nouveaux bombardements ne vont pas
contribuer à apaiser l'atmosphère très
lourde qui règne ici depuis le début de
la crise alors atmosphère très lourde
car on reparle de rumeurs de
déstabilisation menées peut-être par
l'armée serbe présente au monténégro
contre le régime démocratique en place
dans ce pays oui pour comprendre un
petit peu la tension qui règne ici je
vais vous raconter quelque chose qui
s'est passé à c'est signé
la capitale historique du monténégro
c'était il ya quelques jours une dizaine
de soldats de l'armée yougoslave sont
arrivés dans deux familles ils avaient
ordre d'enrôler de force tous les hommes
de cette famille
à ce moment là des gens appartenant à un
mouvement de résistance civile sont
arrivés ils ont désarmé
ces soldats fédéraux et les ont invités
à quitter les lieux
le responsable de ce mouvement de
résistance que nous avons eu cet après
midi au téléphone nous a dit il est hors
de question qu'un citoyen de c'est signé
à y combattre pour slobodan milosevic
cette histoire montre bien la tension
qui règne ici entre deux camps d'un côté
les partisans du président réformateur
milo djukanovic que nous avons
interviewé il ya il y a à peu près une
semaine et qui refuse l'état de guerre
proclamée par slobodan milosevic
de l'autre côté les fédéraux qui sont
toujours fidèles au leader serbe de
belgrade
la tension est à ce point forte en ce
moment qui hier soir le premier ministre
a mis en garde
en garde contre un risque de coups de
contre un risque de guerre civile
ici au monténégro merci maryse et depuis
hier et le conseil européen qui se
tenait à bruxelles en présence du
secrétaire général de l'onu kofi annan
il existe une proposition diplomatiques
des pays de l'union européenne la
proposition d'une force t rès
multinationales faite par monsieur
chirac mais aussi d'un plan allemand de
paix explication richard mines et kofi
annan
entouré des quinze chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens le secrétaire
général de l'onu tenait hier soir la
vedette
apparemment un rôle de guest stars en
fait un invité d'honneur le plan de paix
présenté par le chancelier gerhard
schröder prévoit une trêve de 24 heures
pour permettre à belgrade de retirer ses
troupes
mais il prévoit aussi qu'il doit être
avalisée par le j'évite donc par la
russie permettant ainsi un retour
diplomatique de boris eltsine et surtout
qu'il doit faire l'objet d'une
résolution du conseil de sécurité les
opérations de l'otan disposerait d'une
base légale
les nations unies reprendrait le rôle et
pourrait donner un éventuel feu vert à
une intervention terrestre
pour jacques chirac l'europe doit
prendre ses responsabilités
le président français souhaite que le
kosovo soit placé sous l'administration
de l'union européenne une sorte de
protectorat
après le retrait des forces yougoslaves
mais d'ici là les cinq grands devront
d'abord se mettre d'accord sur le profil
de la future force d'interposition
moscou considère qu'il ne peut s'agir là
que d'une force de paix pékin est
hostile à toute présence étrangère et
pour paris londres et washington
il ne peut s'agir que d'une force armée
on semble changer sur le règlement du
conflit du kosovo monsieur boris eltsine
et a choisi comme représentant spécial
l'ancien premier ministre victor
tchernomirdine qui semble lui plus
enclins à écouter les propositions
européennes il vient d'ailleurs d'être
invité par les autorités allemandes à se
rendre à bonne correspondance à moscou
de gide rabin
c'était il y a un an presque jour pour
jour
deux semaines après avoir été
brutalement limogé par boris eltsine
victor tchernomirdine inusable premier
ministre depuis plus de cinq ans fêtait
son 61e anniversaire sans rancune
apparente pour le président russe
il accueillait aussi son successeur le
très jeune kirienko et images furtives
yves bény primakov de dos qui était à
l'époque le chef de la diplomatie pour
les russes qui ne respectent pas
beaucoup tchernomirdine c'est l'homme
qui a toujours tout accepté sans
broncher ancien apparatchik soviétique
du ces câbles d'énergie
puis premier patron de gazprom le géant
mondial du gaz ce qui lui a valu le
surnom de gaspar a chip
il a eu un jour une phrase malheureuse
qui est devenu malgré lui une sortie des
dictons populaire on a voulu faire de
notre mieux
comme d'habitude ça n'a pas marché si le
président russe que charge du dossier
yougoslave c'est d'abord pour en
décharge et primakov déjà populaire et
qui le deviendraient trop pour yacine
sid réussi à trouver une solution
diplomatique au conflit
excédé par les attaques et des vexations
et mac os s'est mis en congé maladie et
a annulé ses rendez vous après avoir
rappelé qu'il ne s'accrocherait pas un
fauteuil de premier ministre qu'il
n'avait jamais souhaité
première intervention de tchernomirdine
pour dire d'un côté que le plan proposé
par l'allemagne pour l'arrêt des
hostilités méritent d'être examinées
soutenu et de l'autre côté pour
attribuer immédiatement à l'otan
l'attaqué d'un convoi de réfugiés qu'il
qualifie de tragédie et de crimes que
fera t-il que primakov n'aurait pas pu
faire
quelles consignes nouvelle at il reçu de
boris eltsine on n'en saura rien
officiellement et les images de leur
rencontre son maître sans bande son
voilà pour l'actualité au kosovo a
signalé que monsieur chirac recevra
demain après midi les associations et
organisations humanitaires qui
travaillent actuellement sur la crise
sur place en algérie depuis ce matin
c'était le premier tour du scrutin pour
l'élection présidentielle après le
retrait de six candidats sur sept on a
guetté toute la journée le taux de
participation des électeurs algériens
pour l'instant pas de chiffre définitif
mais il semble bien que les votants
étaient beaucoup moins nombreux récit de
cette journée électorale a alger dans un
bureau de vote presque vide avec
dorothée olliéric et christian hottin
quelques cris d'enfants résonnent dans
l'école mohamed bourahla mais pas
l'ombre d'un électeur le vive le silence
l'ennui il est 15 heures le bureau de
vote attend patiemment le client les
premières de d'inscrits 768 inscrit les
communes ont voté pour l'instant sans
mal 10 ans pour cent par rapport aux
dernières élections c'est peu c'est peu
surtout à 15h30 une heure où l'affluence
est d'ordinaire importante c'est peu
mais plus qu'en kabylie où le taux était
à la même heure de 4%
comment pas d'observateurs après pas les
films voilà un batteur de chez vous des
flics à 6 voilà dans d'autres bureaux
doit y avoir d'autre part attendre
on a d'autres où viola pas outrepasser
sont des bois francs le silence éloquent
de sapiac qui ne trouve pas les mots
pour résumer cela un candidat selon
l'ofs abdelaziz bouteflika
l'algérie rêvait d'un scrutin pluraliste
et elle a eu aujourd'hui une élection
aux airs de plébiscite du passé
et moi je ne dirais pas le cas
pourquoi
parce que je n'ai qu'à lire les journaux
c'est pas compliqué ce sont ces hommes
qui ont tout fait basculer les six
rivaux d'abdelaziz bouteflika qui hier
se sont déclarés hors course pour cause
de fraude à nouveau réunis aujourd'hui
pour adopter une position commune
ils n'ont fait à leur sortie que peu de
déclarations situation des élections en
soi recherche pour enfermer un peu plus
le candidat abdelaziz bouteflika
les partisans d'hocine aït ahmed ont
appelé je cite à une marche pacifique
demain contre la dictature
pour tous ceux qui soutiennent les six
candidats qui se sont retirés de la
course l'inquiétude n'est pas le
résultat de ce scrutin qu'ils jugent
d'ores et déjà discréditées
mais l'organisation de la marche de
demain tous pensent qu'elle va être
interdite et tours se demandent s'ils
doivent tout de même bravé cette
interdiction
sachant les conséquences que cela peut
avoir ici en algérie le sol candidats
restent en lice monsieur abdelaziz
bouteflika déclarait ce matin qu'il
tiendrait compte de l'importance du
nombre des électeurs qui se serait
exprimé thierry thulliez bruno girodon
ont rencontré cet après midi monsieur
bouteflika qui évoque le retrait de ses
concurrents et l'éventualité d'une
décision similaire de sa part
au cas où quelques heures avant la
clôture du scrutin avaient l'asis
bouteflika nous reçoit une dernière fois
vous pensiez avant de vous présenter ce
serait aussi compliqué ou si difficile
je n'ai pas eu l'impression que ça a été
plus compliqué a officié ce qui est
compliqué et difficile c'est que ce sont
des choses que je ne peux pas expliquer
mais tout ce que je peux expliquer n'est
pas compliqué difficile
la décision des six est inexplicable
pour moi parce que vraiment par rapport
aux enjeux de la république
si l'absence totale de maturité chez les
patients que c'est un combat de boxe qui
s'est elle même terminé pas que j'aide
l'eponge ce site et des préjugés qui
porte jusqu'à au technique c'est un
arrêt je ne sais pas les gens étaient
sur la reebok et qu'ils ont décidé suite
man 2 mais plus boxé alors pas mon
problème
abandonné pendant l'impression d'avoir
gagné c'est comme un plus fort il faut
être vraiment algérien pour poser les
choses comme cela
les urnes il attend un soutien sans
équivoque des électeurs si je n'ai pas
un soutien franc et massif du peuple
algérien je considère qu'il doit être
dans sa médiocrité
après tout je ne suis pas chargé de
faire son bonheur bien malgré lui je
sais entre chez moi et y rester pendant
vingt ans j'ai déjà prouvé pendant le
passé je ne suis pas un chercheur
pouvoir pas plus car que quelqu'un qui
est atteint de messianisme politique
je sais que mon pays a besoin de
quelqu'un
mais je ne me posais pas qu'ils peuplent
et bien ça veut dire que c'est moi qui
apprécie mal la situation
parce que c'est une décision qui doit
être rapide mais ce que c'est une
décision qui demande du temps
quand je lis tous les éléments
d'appréciation
je m'enferme vrai tout seul dans une
pièce est seul
je prendrai ma décision et selon le cas
je ferai ou ne ferait aucun commentaire
voilà pour l'entretien que vous avez
réalisé thierry thulliez c'est avec
bruno girodon monsieur bouteflika
thierry ce soir est ce que vous avez une
estimation de participation définitif
provisoire pour l'instant provisoire en
fait d'un de 18 heures
et elle nous révèle que le taux de
participation serait supérieure à 50% et
d'après plusieurs sources porches
proches du pouvoir on annonce un taux
qui sera annoncée officiellement entre
55 et 60% alors c'est nettement
inférieur au taux de 75 % de
participation
en 1995 lors de l'élection 12e minérale
mais ce sera peut-être suffisant pour
que abdelaziz bouteflika juge légitime
sur l'élection
alors quel était l'état d'esprit des
algériens aujourd'hui autant vous ayez
pu vous en rencontre avec dorothée
olliéric le sentiment ici c'est d'abord
le vote s'est plutôt déroulée dans le
calme
alger c'est sûr dans l'intérieur du pays
du pays bien coûter on verra ça demain
mais a priori donc c'est plutôt le calme
qui prévaut après le coup de théâtre du
retrait des six on a le sentiment qu'en
fait les algériens ont vu ce coup de
théâtre comme une péripétie politique
ils nous apparaissent en fait plutôt
désabusé c'est vrai qu'ils ont de graves
problèmes on l'a vu le chômage la misère
la paye de l'onp tous la paix et c'est
vrai qu'au fond ils ont regardé ces
élections avec une certaine distance et
il y a une certaine inquiétude puisque
les attendent demain la marche pacifique
et qui espèrent ils escomptent qu'il n'y
aura pas de débordements mais c'est
franchement le le caractère désabusé
algérien qui prédomine ce soir merci
thierry parmi ceux qui se sont abstenus
beaucoup s'appelle entre les patriotes
ils ont choisi depuis de longs mois de
réagir de se battre contre les violences
les actes terroristes et les massacres
hâtive attribués aux islamistes
le pouvoir leur a donné des armes et ils
ne comprennent pas bien pourquoi
maintenant à l'issue de la consultation
électorale présidentielle
il faudrait les rendre et discuter avec
ceux qui l'ont combattu dans les mecs
reportage thierry thulliez bruno girodon
c'est l'accès au maquis de bouhinoun au
dessus de tizi ouzou un chemin
aujourd'hui tranquille que les patriotes
parcours sans grande précaution ce qui à
les écouter n'a pas toujours été le cas
le magasin reculé à côté avant qu'il y
ait des patriotes les groupes du ga
venaient se ravitailler dans ce magasin
est emprunté cette route à travers le
pays ils sont plusieurs dizaines de
milliers à avoir ainsi prêter main forte
à des forces de sécurité souvent
dépassée quand le député nordine aït
hamouda déserte l'assemblée il est le
plus souvent ici au milieu de ces civils
armés par le pouvoir pour défendre leurs
villages
certains reçoivent une solde et ont
derrière eux quatre ans de chasse aux
terroristes eux qui sont si fiers de
montrer le terrain reconquis ne se
sentent pas concernés par l'élection
présidentielle et aucun compte dans ce
qui garantissait démocratie ça même si
c'est le plan militaire les terroristes
ont perdu sur le plan politique
incontestablement il vient de marquer du
dcu a cessé à ses bons
nordine aït hamouda veux parler de la
réconciliation avec les islamistes pro
mu pendant la campagne et c'est un fait
que dans les villages de kabylie où sont
concentrées bons noms de groupes
d'autodéfense
l'idée s'est répandue d'une trahison de
la classe politique
elle est soupçonnée de vouloir négocier
la paix ici chacun a reçu une arme à feu
il ne la rendra qu'incertaine
mais si une opération la sécurité ici on
va déposer les armes
et pourquoi pas un parent dont on n'a
pas confiance
je ne vois pas comment après tout ce qui
s'est passé après autant de morts qu'on
puisse effacer d'un trait de dire non
c'est fini maintenant c'est terminé on
considérera que tout ce qui a eu lieu
jusqu'à maintenant on peut l'effacer
recommencer à zéro ça n'est pas possible
on a été trop loin
on était trop loin devant la barbarie
c'est pas possible nous avoir résisté
aux ja
nous résisterons à tout gouvernement qui
va nous imposer une dictature
nous sommes des gens libres arme est
utilisée par le pouvoir au plus fort de
la violence ils craignent d'être
sacrifiée sur l'autel de la
réconciliation
quelles que soient ses projets le futur
chef de l'état le sait il devra faire
avec cette force de quelques dizaines de
milliers d'hommes peu disposée au
compromis et qui fait tenir un jour un
contrôle et puis à l'occasion de cette
activité algérienne ce disque avec cette
chanson algérie mon amour enregistré par
31 artistes chanteurs et musiciens
algériens autour d'un texte dédié à
l'algérie tout entière
à londres le ministre britannique de
l'intérieur monsieur jack straw a donné
son feu vert à la poursuite de la
procédure d'extradition de l'ancien
dictateur chilien augusto pinochet vers
l'espagne le principe politique que
l'extradition est donc acquis il reste
maintenant à la justice britannique
d'examiner le dossier sur le fond à
londres pour france 2 pascal douce et
mon il a tranché jacques selon la
ministre de l'intérieur britannique
avait à prendre de son propre aveu la
décision la plus difficile de sa
carrière
j'ai décidé de demander à la justice de
procéder à l'extradition du général
pinochet
jeumont explique dans une lettre envoyée
aux deux parties de penser agusto
pinochet sera donc extradé de quoi ravir
ses opposants de toujours inventions
simplement qu'un homme accusé de tant de
crimes ne puisse pas échapper à la
justice car personne ne doit être au
dessus des lois
le mois dernier l'ex dictateur avait
lancé son ultime défi médiatique
l'ancien premier ministre margaret
thatcher était venu réitérer son soutien
un vieil ami 10 et l ironie de
l'histoire c'est elle même qui a signé
en 81
le traité international sur la torture
le texte qui vota augusto pinochet les
ennuis d'aujourd'hui la cour de londres
a fixé au 30 avril la première audience
d'extradition l'avocat du général
n'avait plus qu'a annoncé ce matin la
nouvelle à son client
quant à son collègue chilien il ne cache
pas sa colère
mais le royaume uni dans le camp du
minorité des chiliens qui préfèrent la
zizanie à la réconciliation pour
l'instant augusto pinochet reste assigné
à résidence dans l'ouest londonien son
départ pour l'espagne n'est pas encore
pour demain
le principe de l'extradition est
désormais acquis mais il faut maintenant
en fixer les modalités
et c'est un tribunal pénal de le faire
les avocats du général pinochet dispose
de plusieurs possibilités de recours
tout cela prendra donc plusieurs mois ce
soir le président chilien réaffirme la
souveraineté judiciaire de son pays dans
la sphère à augusto pinochet au pakistan
l'ancien premier ministre madame et
désire buteau il son épouse ont été
condamnés à cinq ans de prison pour
corruption
madame but au chef de file de
l'opposition pakistanaise et son mari
qui est sénateurs vont faire appel
devant la cour suprême d'islamabad
la fédération européenne des retraités
et personnes âgées organisait
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs pays de
l'union européenne des rassemblements de
retraités objet de cette journée
protester contre la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat des retraités le mot d'ordre a
été suivie en belgique en espagne en
italie en grande-bretagne et en france
les manifestations de retraités dans
plusieurs villes françaises étaient
d'inégal importance commentaires emilie
lançons avec christian leroux ils
étaient moins nombreux qu'espéré
quelques centaines tout plus à paris
mais tous étaient déterminés à obtenir
une revalorisation de leur retraite
indique les retraités sont d'une
ancienne elles sont pas tous ces
candidats ya beaucoup de retraités ma
femme notamment qui n'ont eu 3000 francs
tension
je travaillais mêmes revendications pour
les 2500 retraités rassemblés ici à metz
une hausse des pensions et des aides
versées aux personnes seules 24 ans je
suis ça fait plusieurs années que quand
on fait une déclaration d'impôts on a
toujours la même somme d'argent alors
quand même le coût de la vie tous les
ans même si un peu d'inflation on se
rend compte que le conte à une perte
d'argent
l'occasion aussi pour les manifestants
de se prononcer contre un allongement de
la durée des cotisation à 42 ans et demi
préconisée par le rapport charpin en
espagne en italie ou encore en belgique
les retraités ont aussi manifesté dans
les grandes villes une première pour la
fédération européenne des retraités
c'est 15 millions d'adhérents
même si la mobilisation n'a pas vraiment
été à la hauteur de leurs espoirs
un juge d'instruction du tribunal de
paris vient de mettre en examen un
enseignant corse jean castela déjà placé
sous mandat de dépôt pour un attentat
commis en septembre 97 contre l'ena à
strasbourg
monsieur castella est poursuivi dans
d'autres procédures judiciaires dont
celle d'une enquête en marge de
l'assassinât du préfet claude erignac
cette fois jean castela et mis en examen
pour destruction par explosif de biens
immobiliers l'explication michel fine la
charge de 3 kg et est placé en bas à
gauche de la porte d'accès latéral au
bâtiment
ce texte non signé et la revendication
de l'attentât perpétré le 4 septembre 97
contre les locaux de l'ena à strasbourg
le même document revendique l'attentât
de vichy le 11 novembre et surtout une
action commando menée le 5 septembre
contre la gendarmerie de pietrosella
six mois plus tard c'est une arme volée
lors de l'attaqué de cette gendarmerie
qui devait servir à tuer le préfet
erignac
vichy strasbourg pietrosella
l'assassinât du préfet pour les
enquêteurs tout est lié et c'est la
première fois qu'une mise en examen
intervient dans l'un de ces dossiers
elle vise un professeur d'histoire géo à
l'université de corte
jean castela
les policiers ont retrouvé la facture
d'une chambre d'hôtel située à 400
mètres à peine des locaux de l'ena à
strasbourg jean castela aurait séjourné
dans cet hôtel trois mois avant
l'attentât
les enquêteurs pensent qu'il y aurait
effectué des repérages jean castela est
un militant nationaliste de longue date
membres de la conque hoult et du flnc
canal historique
selon nos informations il aurait été
l'un des organisateurs de la fameuse
conférence de presse de très longues en
janvier 96 depuis quels étaient ses
relations avec les chefs du flnc
etait-il comme certains le disent entré
en dissidence c'est toute la question
car jean castela est aujourd'hui au
centre de l'enquêté sur l'assassinât du
préfet erignac le commissaire priseur
maître jacques tajan été mis en examen
pour faux en écriture publique cette
décision est prise dans le cadre de la
procédure faisant suite à la vente d'une
sculpture d'alberto giacometti en 1994
demain présentation officielle à
l'institut mutualiste montsouris à paris
d'une nouvelle technique chirurgicale
développé depuis peu pour le traitement
des cancers de la prostate
ces cancers sont la première cause de
mortalité chez l'homme après 70 ans il
faut intervenir tôt la méthode pratiquée
grâce à un robot assistée par ordinateur
l'institut montsouris réduit
l'hospitalisation reportage d'année
flaysakier naucelle martin les a lisa ne
comprend que l'anglais mais ne la
cherchez pas dans l'équipe médicale lisa
est un robot caméra qui obéit à la voix
et se déplace à la demande une aide
précieuse pour le chirurgien qui perd
ainsi développé la technique
d'intervention en vidéo ici ils enlèvent
la totalité d'une prostate cancéreuses
la prostate est une petite glande d'à
peine 20 g placé sous la vessie
habituellement l'opération se fait en
incisant l'abdomen sur plusieurs
centimètres grâce à lisa on ne sait plus
que cinq trous minuscules une méthode
très performante même si elle alourdit
le travail de chirurgie il faut compter
un temps opératoire double pour la
raison que je vous ai donné c'est qu'en
fait on avance plus doucement pas à pas
en revanche
l'hospitalisation est deux fois plus
courte cette hospitalisation réduite est
due aux suites opératoires simple comme
en témoigne ce patient opéré la bng
petite douleur surtout quand je me lève
mais sinon c'est bien voulu s'y rend
chez un petit peu oui j'ai cet après
midi on se rend compte qu'au deuxième
jour ils ont des douleurs qui est
pratiquement nulle par rapport à changer
cette horreur jeu type là ces messieurs
c'est une douleur qui est qui et qui a
un score de douleur qui est extrêmement
faible on n'a plus besoin de deux portes
algique de médicaments antidouleur fort
et eu des gens sont tout à fait du
mobile sont conçus par la nasa pour les
vols spatiaux
lisa va maintenant retrouver des
occupations plus terre-à-terre pour le
plus grand bien des patients les uns au
théâtre des champs elysées à paris
représentations jusqu'à samedi soir de
l'orfeo de monteverdi
l'oeuvre raconte l'histoire d'orphée
inconsolable de la mort de sa belle
eurydice qui ne parviendra pas à ramener
les enfers c'est la chorégraphe
américaine trisha brown qui a mis en
scène ce qui est considéré comme l'un
des premiers chefs d'oeuvre de l'opéra
avec une partie chantée muhsin parties
dansées présentation d' antoine cormery
et didier rancoeur
ils sont chanteurs d'opéra se sont
produits sur les plus grandes scènes du
monde mais l'exercice auquel les
contraintes trisha brown sort pour eux
un peu de l'ordinaire
sous la férule de la grande chorégraphe
américaine
il répète une dernière fois les
mouvements qu'elle a imaginé pour cette
oeuvre à la frontière du baroque jeu
lors de la mission qui est liée aux
tests et à la musique était de réunir
ces trois choses et ce n'est pas
vraiment de la danse quelque chose entre
le jeu on danse tout en douceur comment
dire aérienne
oh
et
à
et les passages dansés succès tôt
passages chantés pour nous raconter
l'histoire tragique d'orphée amoureux
éperdu d'une heure et dix il ne
parviendra pas à ramener des enfers
et on peut dire que pendant les deux que
ce spectacle lui il n'y a aucun n'a
vraiment aucun geste clichés de chanteur
ce geste là des gestes riche et qu'on
voit tout le temps à l'opéra il n'y a
pas un qu'on peut voir ici
considéré comme l'un des premiers chefs
d'oeuvre de l'opéra cette orfeo de
monteverdi subi quatre siècles après sa
création d'une sacrée cure de jouvence
et chats brogna portes jusqu'au moment
du salut final toute la légèreté de sa
chorégraphie
nous arrivons à la fin de ce journal
avant de le refermer je vous rappelle
deux informations elle concerne tout
d'abord les frappes au kosovo le temps
reconnaît sa responsabilité dans le
bombardement d'un convoi de réfugiés à
l'ouest du kosovo hier bombardement qui
aurait fait plusieurs dizaines de morts
mais les frappes continuent pour cette
23ème nuit depuis le début du conflit
frappe encore ce soir au monténégro et
puis en algérie élections
présidentielles faible taux de
participation sans doute entre 50 et 60%
selon les premières estimations
résultats demain ou dans la nuit le seul
candidat en lice abdelaziz bouteflika
réserve sa décision c'est ce qu'il a dit
aux envoyés spéciaux
thierry thulliez et bernard giraudeau et
puis cette nouvelle qui viennent d'être
annoncées par l' agence france-presse
le juge des murs qui est chargé de la
faire des emplois fictifs à la mairie de
paris se déclare incompétent dans la
sphère qui vise notamment dans le
dossier qui vise notamment le président
de république et un texte qu'il aurait
signé dans un instant la météo de
nathalie rihouet puis le point route de
valérie maurice suivi d'envoyé spécial
qui modifie une troisième fois son
sommaire avec notamment une enquête les
français dans la guerre
un reportage dans le département du lot
reportage réalisé par guilaine chenu
lippi lui aussi un document sur céline
dion à 23h10 comme au cinéma de frédéric
lopez avec christophe lambert vers 1h du
matin le journal de la nuit vous sera
présenté par florence duprat et puis à
13h votre vrai demain rachid arhab et à
20h béatrice schönberg à lundi bonsoir
merci